and you
you who are you
[Music]
uh
um
hmm
ugh heavier than he looks
now listen dawg i have done exactly what
you asked
so lest you and me figure this
hi
[ __ ] quiet
so he doesn't
[Music]
you hear me i need your help
[Music]
a minute
so
[Applause]
last one
[Music]
[Applause]
don't you dare faint again
keep your eyes open [ __ ]
we both could use medical attention do
you know a repadok
whom you can trust
i know someone
we must get the reputation quickly
hector will
fix us up we have to get there somehow
cause someone anyone
all right all right
pretext my scanner indicates you are
outside the service area
just come pick me up
i need to get to miss this esotericate
run a vix of course a vehicle is on
route
it should arrive in less than 20 minutes
what are you doing
hey
the personal link is damaged please
proceed to insert the jack below the ear
though not too deep there should be
auxiliary neural sockets between his
lymph nodes
beneath the scm muscle
[Music]
now proceed to connect
i cannot hold it
i need to rest
that your blood misty
precious tanking it's neurogenic shock
he's dying
gotta cut my way through the occipital
bone no other way
there is risk off i know what i'm doing
so
how is he
slower on the men than you but looking
better every day
fee you in there ah
my head
how you feeling
[ __ ] i don't know vic
here's a ring and i'm seeing [ __ ]
these hallucinations describe them to me
blinding lights it's loud
i'm on stage and i almost can't breathe
i'm so damn full of hatred
then i let it all out into a mic and i
realize
it didn't help i don't feel any better
and then promise not to laugh
i plan a bomb in arasaka tower
there to laugh about
they killed me vic never been so afraid
it was too real even for a lucid dream
you weren't dreaming v those were
memories
there's a personality construct on that
shard dreams you had
or from his past
saying i experienced another psyches
memories
how's that possible you two are
connected in a way i can't make head or
tail of
two me and who vic
who's the other johnny silverhand
a terrorist real talk of the town back
in my day
anyway that's not what's important right
now
never given me that look before vic
what is it you uh
don't get a lot of time left kid say
what now
the biochip it's basically a bomb
fuse lit already you don't have much
time left much
life a few weeks tops
silver hands construct is overriding
your consciousness
gradually taking over your body until
one day you'll just be
gone
[Music]
b it's important you get all this
you'll fix me up right vic
if i could i would be believe me
but this is it's way beyond what i know
how to do
you're the best of the best vic why
can't you help me
you want the long story or the short
don't admit a thing not one deep
okay there was is
a construct a psyche on the chip
out of johnny's silver hand
you jacked it in your chip slot nothing
happened right
until you died bullet in the head from
dexter to sean
but how do you come back from something
like that lord caliber
you lucked out not least thanks to
another poor decision by mr deshawn
bananites off the chip started fixing
the damage
then they took your hand and coaxed you
off the path toward the light
people don't just die and get up like
nothing
happened used to be true now it's only
if they don't have a classified piece of
corporate deck
primed to resurrect them what about me
my psyche i'll make it back from the
other
side and what i'm supposed to pretend
change is normal
ask the arasak engineers who built the
thing
all i know is your mind's gonna go
it won't be pretty
from the biochips perspective your brain
cells are a tumor that needs to be
scooped out
while your body's an empty shell to hold
the construct
so this [ __ ] terrorist wants to wipe
me
and take my place take my body
it's not willful on his part it's
automatic inevitable
and neither of you can stop it
can't we just take the chip out or
switch it off
either ways out of the question you die
immediately
[Music]
vic you've always come through for me
if there's nothing you can do to help me
then
well what the hell do i do tell me
please vic i wish i knew a kid
[Music]
misty
[Music]
you're asking too much from an old-timer
like vic
come on v let's get you home
[Music]
so
and then he died and i thought i was
gonna die
with him in my sleep
sleep's a small hint of death
the inevitable can't actually tell if
i'm awake now
i mean i could be dead already right
not something to focus on v let it go
here got some meds for you
omega blockers taken regularly
they'll keep things from progressing too
quickly
also they should keep that guest of
yours calm and quiet
pseudoendotrizines from me effect will
be opposite
it'll speed things up free the demon so
to speak
giving me a pill to prod that son of a
[ __ ] so he can kill me faster listen
you're likely to be fine for a while but
sometime down the road
it could turn into pure agony
i'm giving you options honey the brain
can be tricked
plain old painkillers do that your
psyche is gonna die
v you'll feel your old self slipping
away
at some point you won't recognize
yourself
it'll be terrifying he'll be painful
but it doesn't have to be the [ __ ] i
need pills for
ought to just stick a gun in my mouth
and pull the trigger
well that way you'd kill two souls is
that what you want
i gotta lie down
here got one more thing for you
vic pulled this out of your skull a
lucky charm
promise you'll try to get some sleep
misty wait um
about jackie yeah
he talked about you
like lots
we got into a fight right before he went
off to do this job
he wasn't mad at you i hope you know
that
i know i just wish our last moments
together could have been
different
but right now you need rest so sleep
please sleep
gotta get out of here understand
and i'll kill anyone who gets in my way
you include
need a smoke where'd you stash yours
don't smoke then go out and get some
just need one last one jesus [ __ ]
christ man
the [ __ ] kind of joy toy are you
supposed to be
[ __ ] ghost off
who you work for start talking
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] chip
rip the thing out myself no wait
ugh
take control
[Music]
i'll find a way
you hear me
see you never [ __ ]
now like that stick some iron in your
mouth and pull the trigger
i can feel it our minds touch it
i'm like mold on fruit creeping into you
nothing i can do about it you hear me
i'd puke if i [ __ ] could it's just a
copy of the engram
oh [ __ ] me
you board up ghouls i got good news cop
cord around your hoods packed up and
left
now let's hear what the rubicons have to
say about it
so
so
so
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
the camera here we must meet
come to thomas diner
why would i do that because i am the one
who saved your life
i haven't managed to get my head
straight yet not after everything that
happened
that will not happen anytime soon and so
what if you intend to leave
you must re-enter the ring the bell has
already told
thomas diner i am waiting
got another dry sun-filled meat
oh [ __ ] not good
hello i'm igbo with wns news
today is a sad one in our city's history
mayor
lucius rein has passed away we learned
family he died peacefully in his sleep
the exact call
but initial reports suggest coronary
implant failure
the remainder of mayor ryan's term will
be fulfilled by his deputy mayor and
closest associate
weldon holt has also announced plans to
run
today we all mourn the untimely loss of
our mayor
[Music]
so
space
me
get away sit
you do not look so bad
then in the car i doubt it you would
survive
why'd you help me anyway i needed you to
leave
that hasn't changed
this about the biochip that why i'm here
i hear it's damaged beyond the repair
any attempt to extract
it would be disastrous fatal for you
vic likes to talk i guess not many could
do what
he did you should be thankful
what you actually want from me
to begin you must tell me where to find
evelyn parker evelyn what's you to you
she and jorino varasaka had intimate
relations
she knows how to get to him i've been
thinking i would have a word with her
myself
she promised to help me get rid of the
chip i would not count on that
she's likely gone very far away
just answered your own question about
where evelyn is
long gone
why do you believe she could help you
remove the chip
does a cooperation help her
you ask a lot of questions you have many
interesting things to say might be your
turn now to say something interesting
i intend to punish your innovo arasaka
siviri
for the crime he has committed
sorry couldn't be of any help don't have
any time to lose
so wait i need you
yorinobu arasaka must answer for this
crime
of patricide looking for justice
in night city i seek revenge
much more feasible here i have allies
prepared to bring
ryorinova to his knees the only thing i
need
is proof and you think they'll trust the
word of a merc
i have nothing better now also i know
no one here and i am a fugitive
i am hunted
so what we stroll into arasaka hq and
announce that yorinobu is a kin-killer
that he murdered sabro we'll get the
hearing before reasonable people
in a neutral location certain
procedures will be used to establish the
truth
a lie detector forget it
in that case another option
you are dying you do not know how to
save yourself
a chip the relic is a culprit
technology made by arasaka technology
they alone know
this cooperation can save you as easy as
it can make you disappear
it is merely about getting the right
people on your side
politics you mean people like anders
hellman
you know this name how prepped for the
heist
thoroughly relic is hellman's design his
creation
untrue he's a poem i was thinking of one
much more powerful besides
anders helmer to arasaka betrayed it
soccer scums everywhere hey
i was listening to that shut up nobody
except you wants to watch that [ __ ]
about that corpo [ __ ]
what did you say you heard me
let it go takamura
at least one of yous got some [ __ ]
sense
tom's all right not afraid to speak his
mind that's all
he reminds me of my father he also
worked
in a kitchen all his life
thanks for the offer i need to think
about it
get back to you i need time
to plan organize you stand to gain much
if you help me
all i ask is that you do not leave the
city
leave why would i leave need help best
chance i'll find the right person here
someone other than arasaka specialist
there's no one
no alternative actually we just talked
about some
with a bit of luck i'll track down
evelyn
if she could not help you before she
will not
manage to die honor among thieves
ever heard of it yes i thought it ironic
thieves have that there's just honor i
believe
your noble arasaka would agree i'm sure
that parker woman will not help you
why you i would think about the plan b
honor
anders hellman he invented the relic
[ __ ] and if that means picking another
fight with arasaka
so be it hellman defected from the
company
i myself spent many days looking for him
he what's the expression
dropped off the face of the earth
why are you looking for a helmet he was
the one to allow
sabrosan to urinable skins he knew
both of them well and could be an
important witness
corporal rats will squeal when hanging
by their tails
for several days i collected the
information
always point to one place the club
called the afterlife
i was quickly dismissed by the queen of
fixers there rogue
mean to say you worked for saburo yet
got no idea how to talk to the high and
mighty
she wished to have nothing to do with
the man accused of
mothering sabro arasaka rogue's well
informed
gets wind of most things that happened
in the city might be worth asking her
about hellman
i wish you luck dolma is choosy
expensive and rude
i cannot stay here any longer do what
you want
look for parker helmer forever i must
see some
friends calling some favors
when my people in arasaka are ready to
listen i will call you
till then i guess you buy some miracle
you find
hellman please notify me he and i have
unfinished business
zapper doubles and filth in some ways
night city never changes
our soccer's still a despotic machine in
the world's on a collision course with
chaos
but hey at least rogue's still alive
leave me the [ __ ] alone you don't need
to speak out loud to talk to me
what do you want from me are you still
upset about the other night
you tried to kill me well i gave it some
thought it changed my mind
don't watch your dead anymore [ __ ] off
you psychopath
hey wasn't easy for me either you woke
up in a landfill i woke up in your head
wrestling with your thoughts memories
think we're even
and i've taken a step back looked at
things
think we might be able to help each
other we could start with rogue
her and i go back to the stone age
you're the ghost of christmas past
[ __ ] any friends you had are either
dead
or so old their memory's gone johnny
silverhand died a legend nobody forgets
that
so you [ __ ] know rogue what do i say
to her
a talking brain tumor claims it's her
old friend johnny
trust me rogues are dumber [ __ ] than
that way back when you weren't even an
itch in your daddy's ball sack don't
need convince
seeing your memories gross
rogel danced any two-night player just
get us to the afterlife
there is no use